direction la baie de puno à mourir
[Musique]
jeudi soir il ya trois plongeurs qui
vont passer 24 heures de danse vont
passer leur première nuit sous l'eau
dans la capsule un outil mais si on est
là qu'elle avalait nous voulions dire
bonjour
et les regards
ça fait des mois des années même qu'ils
attendent cet instant emmanuelle et
ghislain bardout plongeurs d'exception
vont mettre la capsule à l'eau je vois
dans la vie et 60 étant quand même un
habitat souvent qu'on a imaginé qu'on a
construit qu'on a amené ici on va le
mettre là où on va vivre l'expérience
pendant deux mois c'est pas rien j'ai
vraiment hâte de la voir de l'avoir dans
le fond dans le décor
dans son jardin quoi et
allez jeter un oeil à l'intérieur
ghislain et emmanuel s'apprête à
l'immerger face à la baie d'opunohu sur
la pente du récif à l'extérieur du lago
par 23 mètres dos et
[Musique]
la capsule 4 mètres cubes à peine 1
habitats subaquatiques uniques imaginées
par l'équipe dunder impôts l'objectif
resté le plus longtemps sous la mer pour
mieux l'observer
mais c'est un prototype il n'y a jamais
eu aucun effet sur le terrain
un tout prévu en ingénierie non tout va
bien se passer quand un ingénieur te
parle comme ça c'est que il a oublié la
moitié des trucs mais c'est pas grave
parce que y'a une équipe de plongeurs
l'équipe sur le bateau s'est un peu tous
des vieux soldats donc ils s'adapteront
à ce qu à l'imprévu qui va forcément se
passer
il ya beaucoup de choses à faire et à
faire bien donc ça va être
voilà demandé pas mal de synchronisation
comme tout le monde moi je ressens un
peu de tension pour brest
bon bah loupé quoi faire les choses
comme il faut
on va y aller on va désamarrée la
capsule et ensuite on va la faire rouler
oui
attention donc
une bulle d'air se forme dans l'un des
dômes de la capsule
elle reste en surface elle ne plonge pas
comme espéré
on
en reste à l'accord acté
c'est parti
l'air est expulsé et la capsule gagne
enfin les faux
[Musique]
moment irréel
j'ai l'impression
presque de vivre un atterrissage d'avion
les élingues pendant qu'il a la bonne
hauteur
emmanuelle et moi on s'en saisit
[Musique]
on accroche la capsule aux quatre coins
de nos ballast
et finalement
en quelques secondes la capsule est en
place
lorsqu'il fixe la capsule c'est
l'aboutissement de trois ans de travail
trois ans de réflexion et de doutes
entre deux expéditions
c'est un moment rare où emmanuel et
ghislain voient leur rêve devenir
réalité
orwell niveau décent c'est un grand
grand grand moment
[Musique]
la capsule est en train de prendre vie
sous les yeux
sur son site
et ça y est là dans quelques secondes si
tout va bien on va on va vivre
l'expérience
pour la première fois sous mes yeux se
présente la capsule
et alors là j'en peux plus j'attends
qu'une chose c'est de rentrer dedans
j'enlève mon recycleurs jeu le suspens
est en apnée je glisse vers le saas
j'émerge
la tête à l'air à l'intérieur de la
capsule est là et l'or et c'est un grand
grand grand grand moment de bonheur et
de joie
je crie je crie je crie
[Musique]
l'invention fonctionne
vie
[Musique]
l'idée est né d'une frustration de
plongeurs celle de devoir toujours
remonter trop tôt à la surface
sur les plantes détail ordinateur chaque
élingues arrive sur une roche eir sont
résistants ce qu'elle a
ghislain emmanuel scott cameron et
sylvain pujol imagine alors un habitat
sous marin unique un habitat que l'on
peut transporter facilement dans le
monde entier installez simplement par
une équipe de plongeurs et sans impact
sur l'environnement
la capsule est composé de plusieurs
parties
l'espace de vie qui peut abriter trois
plongeurs
et reliés par des câbles à des ballasts
de 6 tonnes qui sont remplis évident et
d'eau pour être positionné avec
précision la capsule est autonome mais
une équipe de surface est un camp de
base assure logistique et sécurité la
capsule n'est pas juste un fantasme de
plongeurs le but c'est pas de s'amuser à
faire une petite cabane au fond de l'eau
c'est de donner un outil à des
scientifiques demain aujourd'hui
pour faire des choses dans lequel la
capsule finalement ne sera qu'en multi
au sein d'une démarche plus complexes de
l'étude du récif l'étude à long terme
à moorea la capsule est installé dans
l'un des écosystèmes les plus riches qui
soit mais aussi l'un des plus menacés
aujourd'hui
les récifs coralliens
laetitia est loin en est une spécialiste
au sein du criobe un laboratoire dédié à
l'étude des écosystèmes coralliens elle
cherche à développer des supers corps ou
résistant au changement climatique
selon elle la capsule permettrait de
récolter des informations précieuses sur
la reproduction de chorales
on va vérifier s'il ya des acropora qui
sont matures en socaliste principalement
sur les pulls craint donc on va couper
un morceau de chèques et regarde si on
voit des ovocytes nature si jamais on
voit rien on regarde quand même d'autres
individus et du coup si on a le temps on
garde notre espèce
laetitia entretient une pépinière
coralliens
les récifs coralliens sont avec les
forêts tropicales les écosystèmes les
plus riches de la planète un quart de la
faune et de la flore océaniques en
dépendent
mais les coraux sont extrêmement
sensibles aux variations de température
et subissent de plein fouet les effets
du réchauffement climatique
dans la pépinière laetitia développe des
corps aux résistants à ces évolutions
pour sauvegarder les récifs
un but depuis qu'elle a vu celui de
moorea dévasté
en 2010 bah oui on peut quand même dire
que l'état était catastrophique parce
qu'il restait que 2 % des coraux sur
l'entente externe et donc c'est vrai que
moi je me suis vraiment posé la question
si le récif allait rester dans cet état
où allait pouvoir revenir ça me semblait
un peu impossible qu'il revienne et
pourtant aujourd'hui quand on va nous
plonger on voit qui est à peu près 60%
de revendre encore rien donc le récit
fait vraiment revenus et les revenus
grâce à la reproduction sexuée à cet
apport de large sur l'horizon donc nous
en laboratoire en l'étudier et on étudie
notamment pour faire essayer de faire
des élevages de super large c'est-à-dire
des lacs qui soient plus résistantes aux
changements futurs et notamment
changement climatique
[Musique]
mais pour la première fois depuis 2010
les coraux de la pente externe du récif
de moorea là où est située la capsule
viennent de vivre un nouvel épisode de
blanchissement
lorsque la température est trop élevée
les coraux perdre leur algues qui leur
donnent leur couleur
ils blanchissent
et peuvent en mourir
[Musique]
pour laetitia la ponte à l'extérieur du
lagon sur le récif reste un mystère elle
n'a jamais été observé en polynésie
elle accueille emmanuel ghislain et
toute leur équipe dans son laboratoire
et donc on attend qui pendent dans les
jours qui arrivent d'accord c'est l'écho
alors là c'est des coraux dit lagon
ce que tu vas nous sur la pépinière ils
sont quasi tous matures en 18 mois ils
ont à peu près atteint tu vois cette
taille-là quoi les taux de dépôt et
d'affronter à l'interdît lagos et les
pronostics alors à l'intérieur du lagon
au final c'est acropora là on a été trop
impacter ce que tu vas nous sur la
pépinière ils sont quasi tous matures
par contre quand on compare à l'état du
récif sur la pente externe va là on n'a
pas du tout la même histoire parce que
on a à peine un tiers des colonies qui
sont matures et qui ont des oeufs donc
on voit vraiment que la pente externe a
été beaucoup plus touchée par l'épisode
de blanchissement qui a eu que le lagon
la capsule doit permettre de révéler ce
qui n'a jamais été vu la ponte des
coraux à l'extérieur du lagon sur la
pente du récif l'environnement ne va pas
forcément dans une bonne direction et
donc on a un peu d'espoir je dirais en
essayant de développer des supers coraux
mais du coup pour ça on a vraiment
besoin d'avoir géré dès qu'on descend
des connaissances fondamentales sur
quand est ce que les corps pondent
à quelle heure sur quel site à quelle
profondeur
c'est le jour de la première plongée de
24 heures dans la capsule
24 heures loin de tout
ghislain silva et victor le caméraman
passe des tests physiologiques
les séjours dans la capsule sont des
protocoles de plonger encore inconnue il
nécessite un suivi permanent
c'est bien
[Musique]
hier
bisous aussi un robot mais robben le
revois tout à l'heure alors que moi moi
je vais dans la capsule elle revient
demain
[Musique]
sur le bateau au moment de la mise à
l'eau il y à l'atmosphère des premières
fois
dans leurs regards ont saisi les
questions qui sont encore sans réponse
c'est une sensation étrange de se dire
qu'on peut pour ne pas remonter pour
rester au fond de la mer ça m'interpelle
comme si on faisait quelque chose contre
nature
je dis au revoir et merci à l'équipe
je fait des signes à mon fils robin et
j'y vais
[Musique]
je n'ai aucune appréhension
j'ai une seule certitude
on va vivre une expérience
extraordinaire et le sens vont être
bousculées
[Musique]
dans la capsule les plongeurs ne respire
pas de l'air nocif au delà de quinze
mètres de fond lors de séjours prolongés
mais un mélange d'hélium et d'oxygène
on voit les voix sont déformés par les
lionnes
le but de cette plongée vérifier les
capteurs les donnaient s'assurer que
tout fonctionne que l'on peut il passer
du temps sans danger
ce n'est pas une plongée d'observation
mais évidemment dès qu'ils se posent
observez occupent tout leur temps
on a quitté la surface
je vais au fond de l'année 1 et mon
projet c'est de ne pas remonter
la première fois de ma vie
où j'ai le temps en plongée
suit en tee shirt
et en short
parlant des deux chambres
[Musique]
où
là
j'aurais nîmes ol
[Musique]
ce mois se découvre comme une ville
avec ses habitants qui court qui
interagissent
j'en comprends pas encore tous les codes
et les mécanismes
[Musique]
mais on voit bien que là sous nos yeux
le récif déborde d'une activité
structurée orchestrée
par un ordre invisible
[Musique]
allô allô oui là est-ce que tu m'entends
à l'ovale au bilan est ce que tu
m'entends
oui allô
salut comment ça va dans la capsule
et ben écoute ça se passe bien ça y est
en
s'apprête à passer notre première nuit
sous la mer
moi ta place je sais pas si je dormirai
sur les deux oreilles mais je me
souhaite un peu spécial quand même
on
se balance légèrement il ya un tout
petit peu de courant là tu as avec les
vagues aussi au sens donc et il n'y a
pas trop d'appréhension avant la nuit
c'est quand même un peu impressionnant
et pas trop voilà
voilà
qu'il impose son basque à portée de main
une bouteille de secours et sous chaque
banet
les risques existent une atmosphère
détérioré un câble qui lâche et leur vie
est en jeu
[Musique]
je dors puis je me réveille
il est une heure du matin
je jette un regard où différents écrans
de la capsule tout va bien
les parois sont humides cause de la
condensation
puis le temps passe
je me tourne
je regarde à travers les dom
et c'est une autre vie qui s'anime
celle du plancton
qui vient s'animer dans dans une
multitude de danse frénétique devant nos
projecteurs
et puis celles de prédateurs qui
arpentent le récif qu'on voit tourner
autour de la capsule
les poissons trompette
et puis
j'entends le chant des baleines
qui se rapproche
il se rapproche très très près et au
milieu de la nuit
on a des baleines qui sont juste là à
côté de la capsule
elles doivent être à quelques dizaines
de mètres de la capsule c'est sûr
on sent vibrer la capsule
mais on les voit pas
[Musique]
les baleines nagent autour de la capsule
mais elle se montre rarement aux
plongeurs
qui se succèdent dorénavant dans
l'habitat pour des durées de trois jours
consécutifs
quinze plongeurs y séjournent 60 18
heures
tous vivent à peu près la même chose
l'appréhension initial les premières 24
heures difficiles l'adaptation des sens
il vit à billy's le concept multiplie
les excursions depuis la capsule
[Musique]
tous sont marqués par l'état des coraux
particulièrement abîmée sur cette pente
externe du récif
mais ce long séjour sous marin modifie
aussi leur regard sur la vie récifal
resté trois jours sous les changes les
perceptions
j'ai l'impression de découvrir avec des
yeux nouveaux la vie marine pour la
première fois et j'ai toujours eu
l'impression
de faire que des incursions dans le
milieu sous marin et de regarder les
poissons à 15'' l'extérieur et là d'un
coup je regarde je regarde une vie
s'éveiller le matin une vie se coucher
le soir et en trois jours sous la mer
j'ai l'impression de mieux connaître les
poissons qu'en 15 ans de plongée sous
marine
la vie dans la capsule est une aventure
humaine
on voit
[Musique]
pas les picards bonheur pour ce soir oui
or n'a pas de procès
il y a de la joie des rires
mais parfois des doutes lorsqu une
élingue menace de rompre mettant leur
sécurité en jeu
ou lorsque l'injecteur d'oxygène
à des ratés
[Musique]
quelle que soit la durée passée dans la
capsule il faut quatre heures pour
revenir en surface et retrouver les
sensations disparu soul
je pense que c'est la seule fois de ma
vie vous ça m'est arrivé d'avoir
l'impression de regarder trois jours
derrière moi comme si j'avais été trois
jours dans un
way dans un grand rêve dans un truc un
peu irréel quoi
[Musique]
oui j'ai comme dans le cas d'un
bon ça reste une expérience inoubliable
reste est incroyable
c'est dur de revenir sur terre et se
dire que c'est un peu c'est un peu un
rêve par un rêve qui est finie quoi
les retours sont un événement
[Musique]
malgré l'expérience extraordinaire
partagé par tous
l'inquiétude s'est amplifiée sur l'état
des coraux autour de la capsule
[Musique]
laetitia et doit accompagner ghislain
pour dresser un état plus claire de la
situation sur la pente externe et voir
si la capsule peut permettre d'assister
à une ponte les forces possibles qui est
très peu de co2 soit mature parce qu'ils
ont déjà été beaucoup stressé donc il va
peut-être falloir ont regardé un grand
nombre de colonies pour arriver à
trouver des colonies matures
laetitia s'intéresse particulièrement à
l'espèce acropora yacine tus
et ce qu'elle découvre est pire que ce
qu'elle imaginait
il trouve 215 colonies d'accrocs porat
autour de la capsule
seuls 15 sont vivantes et parmi elles
quatre seulement sont matures
ils les identifie les marques
mais elles sont trop éloignés pour que
les plongeurs puisse observer la pompe
depuis la capsule
il faudra trouver un autre moyen
c'est un peu un choc parce que c'est
vrai que jusqu'à présent on a effacé
vraiment des comptages ont qu'on n'avait
pas vraiment estimé la perte qu'on veut
avoir et là c'est vrai que ceux d'hier
qui a que 6 % des individus que sur les
gus c'est quand même très vite et
pourquoi
4,5 colonies qui ont des deux pourquoi
les autres n'en ont pas en raison de
l'épisode de réchauffement et plus tard
pendant trois quatre mois en quelque
sorte elles ont utilisé toute l'énergie
qu'ils avaient pour la survie relire
pour essayer de passer cet épisode
anormale de température et tu qu elles
ont pas du tout nbc la gamme est au
générique parce que les octrois là ils
ont mis neuf mois à être fabriquée par
l'écho est en gros début de la gamme et
au gnl au début de la fabrication des
objets ya eu l'épisode de blanchissement
est en quelque sorte il ya plein de
colonies qui du coup ont pas investi
dans la reproduction parce qu'elle avait
besoin de toute leur énergie pour
combattre en quelque sorte cette maladie
[Musique]
la période de ponte commencent
tous les soirs laetitia observe les
colonies qu'elle a prélevé dans le lagon
la ponte en aquarium annonce que celle
sur le récif est proche
et les égouts sont reçus
donc pouvoir d isoler une forme avoir
collecté mes voeux des tice à
chaque espèces coralliennes en quelque
sorte son roman de comptes et donc on
sait que sur cette espèce en général il
compte bientôt perdre sept à douze jours
après la famine et il faut souvent 21h
en polynésie il n'y a pas de ponte
massive comme sur la grande barrière de
corail australienne
chaque espèce pont séparément à une
heure très précises cela dure quelques
minutes à peine
pour cette raison elle est très
difficile à observer en milieu naturel
notamment sur la pente externe des
récits
dans le laboratoire une colonie se
mettent à pompe combien
de puis une autre et encore une autre
laeticia son équipe collecte les eaux à
partir desquels ils essaient de créer
ces super coraux qui serait résistant au
changement climatique
mais la ponte en laboratoire n'est pas
la ponte en milieu naturel
pour compléter leurs observations il va
falloir plonger sur le récif
[Musique]
l'équipe de under the pole met tout en
oeuvre pour capter ce moment jamais
observé en polynésie
frangaz zola et victor o plonge nuit
après nuit jusqu'à pouvoir le film
on partait vraiment ultra motivés
et puis bah trois heures sans bouger à
côté d'une colonie dans le noir
on a eu froid c'était long et puis
j'avoue qu'à partir de la soirée numéro
trois là le temps commence à être être
un peu plus long et puis à un moment
donné où le doute s'installe on se
demande si vraiment on va assister à cet
épisode et puis c'est la cinquième
soirée alors là on demande beaucoup dont
on a besoin d'être rassurée par les
scientifiques du crioc par par laetitia
lui demandant est ce que tu es sûr
et quand on est arrivés sur la colonie
ce huitième soir c'était elle était
complètement différente
les autres soirées
laetitia nous avait dit vous verrez
quand ça va pondre vous saurez le
reconnaître
[Musique]
ils assistent enfin à ce délicat moment
dix minutes
pendant lesquelles une colonie plus
résistante que les autres essaient de se
reproduire sur un récif désolé
la date l'heure le site de la ponte de
cette colonie résiliente sont des
indications précieuses pour laëtitia
dans sa quête de super court
[Applaudissements]
voilà cette observation cette grande
preuve pour nous on police
la prochaine fois elle l'observera
peut-être de la capsule
ghislain emmanuel et toute l'équipe
l'ont testé pendant deux mois
elle fonctionne elle a permis d
observation inédite sur la vie récifal
l'aboutissement d'un rêve
le début de nouvelles découvertes